yesterday he was telling the kids to be
quiet
i hear you talking but i can't
understand you can you speed it up
you got anything on you i need to
make sure my door is secured
locked we will secure it i need to make
sure i will make sure who are you are
you just hard here i am the sergeant go
get your car
no i want my sketchers please
listen we played this game with you
yesterday
okay
there's two sides to every story there
is you haven't heard this you will have
your day in court but you had your
opportunity to tell your side of the
story yesterday and you didn't
i said right here you told us no so
you made a piss poor decision now you're
gonna live with it we're trying to help
you out man we're getting your shoes
okay these are flipping it doesn't
matter they're gonna put slides on you
when you get out there can i please have
my sketchers i have bad feet
i have to have shoes on that's
why i stayed home all day on my head
today i have to have my shoes sucked
sorry yes
sir please no listen it's those are
nothing put them on or they're going
back in their
you're holding something against me and
what happened yesterday now you're under
arrest you can put those on and you can
walk out to the car with nothing on your
feet
we're not waiters we're deputies are you
safer waited sir
we'll have your house secured then you
can get it
aggravated stalking
we're not gonna argue we're not gonna
discuss it that's your charge period you
want to discuss it that guy's called a
judge we're not judges
okay came to the door last night and
gave us some information we failed to do
it so we had to make our decisions based
upon what we had period we're not
arguing well i'm not going to argue it
there's two sides to every story
and what you've heard of there once
again so you can argue your side in
court
not out here
what do you think about this civil war
going on get in the car
okay